[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
episode von lukas kommentiert kommentare
danke für deinen kommentar
stoppt bevor du weiter scrolls lächle
doch mal steht dir
dank wer guckt dass auch 2020 dachte am
anfang du machst endlich ein wie man
klatschen durchs zimmer läuft tutorial
danach haben mich wirklich sehr sehr
viele von euch gefragt und zwar laufe
ich ja oft klatschen durch mein zimmer
haben das kann ich euch sehr gern dabei
bringen uns was das wichtigste dabei
dass ihr vernünftiges schuhwerk an habt
ich beispielsweise trage immer an meinem
linken fuß einen wanderschuhen an meinem
rechten fuß in die höhe
da gibts eigentlich gar nicht mehr viel
zu beachten hier fand einfach anderen
klatscht auch dabei ein bisschen rum
schaut ein bisschen rum ist natürlich
immer weiter nachdem ich nichts mehr
gelaufen seid müsst euch natürlich auch
eine spur wieder ausziehen das auf jeden
fall mit meinem klatschen durchs zimmer
laufen tutorial ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen ich hoffe ich konnte etwas
lernen und könnt ihr mir jetzt auch
klatschen durch euer zimmer laufen mit
dem nächsten kommentar und zwar in
england unter mein video geschrieben ja
danke für den freundlichen kommentar
wollte ich immer zu sehen dass auch
leute aus anderen ländern meinen content
feiern
es war einmal eine fette kuh die
hilfsschule sie war so fett dass sie
nicht durch die trip haste warnung
dieser kommentar sollen nur jude die kuh
beleidigen aber keine dicke leute ps
juni popel fressen
julia guck mal das hat einer über dich
geschrieben
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
neues buch von lucca so klatscht man
richtig neues ding ganz kurze sache die
ich jetzt gerade erst in dieser auf nach
bisher und zwar wie kraft der azeti da
bitte ich darf so hart spielen wie ich
will dir auch luca du stinkst nach lucca
best you tube
ich denke schon dass ich habe einen
blinden meinen platz im bus angeboten
andreas 35 ist nun kein busfahrer man
mich zum lachen bringen allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten kommentar
und zwar du könntest im theater sitzen
und die ganze zeit klatschen wäre ein
guter job für dich ja kommentiert doch
allemal diesen klatschen dem motto unter
dem video und dann die klatschen
kommentare glaube ich endlich mal vorbei
haidu brokkoli gesicht du stinkst nach
popel also ich denke nach lucca beste
youtuber ich denke nach popel und jule
frist popel verdammt das heißt juli
könnte mich mal fressen wollen ich habe
mir letztens ein dach gekauft ging aufs
haus hallo
ja heidi egal was games ich bin 80
ich bin 23
seither meine lieben freunde hält wenn
ich so mega eintritt führen schreibt sie
auch den kunden in die kommentare
favorisiert like dass wir in jedem kanal
noch was sagt der gegner in fortnight
wenn luca ihn weg laser weg laser laser
okay du bist kacke ich muss irgendwie
immer lachen aber irgendwie muss sie
auch heulen weil der will mich schon
jemand beleidigen und ein schiff zieht
es mich mal luca ist basti jona dir das
ist was was ich sehr empfehlen würde du
bist schon ein kleiner dreckiger
wadenbeißer ich bin also klein dann bin
ich dreckig weil ich mich anscheinend
länger nicht gewaschen habe und ich
beiße im wagen das typische was an
dieser stelle was schickt die polizei
wenn bei adidas eingebrochen werte drei
strecken
wer hat euch ins hirn gespritzt
allerdings nur doch schon zum letzten
kommentar heute und zwar diesem hier
auch luca wo ist eigentlich laut
flughafen
wenn du einen laden betritt geht sofort
der rauchmelder an der stelle soll die
videos alles aber entweder dem
freudenberg zu noch wenige euro kommt es
an gefeiert hat das gerne einen daumen
hoch bei diesem grund nicht nur in der
dunklen seite und am 16
um 15 uhr kommen neue klamotten immer
wieder von de unter anderem auch die
dann heißt der rudi den ich hier gerade
an ra oder auch beispielsweise dieses t
shirt und ganz viele andere sachen
kommen am samstag um 15 und neun meinen
shop von jeder bestellung der neuen
produkte spenden wie ein euro an die
stiftung gegen rassismus also tut auch
noch was gutes also ich würde mich sehr
freuen wenn ihr am samstag um 15 uhr
shop vorbeischauen würde und jetzt kommt
das auto
[Musik]